LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to
Google Developers Weekly
for November 18, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the world
of Google Developers on the set
and off.
I often say that
Google's the biggest
startup I've ever worked for.
But if your startup
is smaller than ours,
you might be considering
working with an accelerator,
like 500 Startups or Rocket
Space, trading equity
for benefits, like office
space and business strategy.
Is it worth it?
Don Dodge shares his experience
with us and provides advice.
Also, many startups these days
selling premium services find
themselves caught between
free open source software
and large software packages
from bigger competitors offering
support and consulting.
How can you survive?
Jay Simons, president
of Atlassian,
joins Don to talk about how
they navigate this challenge.
From New York,
YouTube's Ikai Lan
shows us how to manually
create Google credential
instances with refresh tokens
as well as access tokens.
If you've been looking
for tips and tricks
on how to use OAuth
with the Java API,
this is the show for you.
Native applications
that run in Chrome
are a big part of the
web as a platform.
Portable Native Client,
or as we call it,
PNaCl, enables secure
and portable execution
of these native apps.
When you produce a
platform-independent form
of your native app,
Chrome translates
it to run on users' portable
devices at greater than 80%
of native performance--
very cool stuff.
Check out the video with
moderator Colt McAnlis and some
of Google's product leads on
Native Client to learn more.
Francesc Campoy and
Kurt Schwehr teamed up
to show us how they leveraged
Google's cloud and Go language
to visualize big data, building
an app that maps shipping
using the Google Maps API.
We brought you clouds
to Google Earth,
and now you can see what
maps can do with cloud.
Staying in a Google
Maps state of mind,
GDL hosted Ujaval Gandhi, author
of the new Google Maps Engine
QGIS Connector, about
how this plug-in fits
into a typical
workflow and where
you can get the source code.
We also welcome back
Peng Ying and Maru
as they dive into
Wallet Objects concepts,
showing us how Wallet Objects
are represented and rendered
in the Google Wallet app.
I tend to know what few objects
are in my physical wallet,
and now, I'll know what objects
are in my Google Wallet, too.
Cloud platform
Maven Paul Rashidi
then joins us for a quick
walkthrough of the Google
Compute Engine API on
Android, demoing a sample app
that connects to the
Google Compute Engine API.
And all week, we've been
happy to host four new courses
from the Google
Developers Hackademy.
This week focused on the
Android SDK presented
by Enrique Diaz from
the GDG Androititlan--
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
Stepping outside the
studio, we have more updates
from the world of
Google Developers.
On Thursday, we celebrate
an important milestone
as Dart turned 1.0.
Dart is a modern language for
building structured web apps,
and now, it's officially ready
for your production apps.
Find out all the cool details
at dartlang.org and get started.
You already know that you
can use a Google Drive
SDK to build apps that are
highly integrated with Drive.
And now, there's a powerful new
way to integrate with Gmail.
Use the new SDK features to
make drive-enabled apps that
let users open docs in your
app without ever leaving Gmail.
And to make sure that you never
miss a thing from the world
of Google Developers, subscribe
to Google Developers on YouTube
and check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.